he's a good friend of mine he um you
know
has been so helpful
for me um in terms of just like dealing
with
fame for billy eilish justin bieber is
anything but a bad guy i'm the bad
guy duh in fact
she says the canadian superstar has
helped her navigate fame
but it was amazing he's so sweet the 19
year old grammy winner joined the
morning mashup on
siriusxm hits one on thursday to talk
about her new album happier than ever
and took a minute to gush over the yummy
singer can you get in the studio with
justin please
make it happen yeah
he's just the sweetest baby ever i love
him
of course billy's loved justin for a
long
time it started when i was like 12 i
believe
yeah back in 2019 before the two had met
she told et
he was her first celebrity crush did you
have posters in your room i did
yeah like big ass ones and she told et
justin actually reached out to her in
her dms is anyone sliding into those dms
yet
i mean bieber did what did he say well
the first thing he sent was a screenshot
of a dm i sent him in 2014.
stop so he remembered from 20. he didn't
remember it but you know
when you follow somebody yeah you can
see everything they've dm'd you in the
past
right so when he started following you
he got the notification
yeah oh what should i do for your heart
that's amazing it like felt good and it
felt bad at the same time yeah
of course since then the two have
collaborated on a remix of bad guy
yeah i'm a bad guy
[Music]
and forged a pretty solid friendship in
the process
so incredible and it was so amazing and
on thursday
billy said justin has helped her learn
how to manage fame
and all that comes with it he's a good
friend of mine he um
you know has been so
helpful for me um in terms of just like
dealing with
fame um and he'll call me sometimes and
just say
stuff that makes me just feel hurt and
like
there's somebody else that goes through
this and stuff so it's really nice
on friday billy released her highly
anticipated
sophomore album and the music video for
the title track happier than ever
billy's happier than ever world tour is
already sold out and kicks off february
3rd
2022 and during her chat with a morning
mashup
she explained how the pandemic changed
her perspective on performing live
it made me realize how many things that
i wasn't
really aware of were as amazing as they
were that then the pandemic took away
and i was like
oh okay
cool and i think that i i i never
want to not do shows again that's really
how i feel you know i think i used to be
like
in the future maybe i'll not do shows
maybe i'll like take a
year off and now i'm like i don't have
an interest in that
anymore and when asked about all her
success and whether or not she ever
thought she'd make it this far
well here's what she had to say i could
never have
thought this would happen in my life